the ministry of agriculture fisheries
food security and rural development
in collaboration with world university
service of canada
have engaged local farmers in a series
of training workshops on the role of
vegetable grafting in climate smart
agriculture strategies
according to crop protection officer
johnny smith
this intervention will facilitate a more
reliable and consistent supply of
produce to the market so the current
grafting training covers a
theoretical session and it covers a
practical session
so we have the morning we normally start
at nine and we run until one
we start with lectures on
the work that has been done locally
on grafting vegetables so we've looked
at
grafting tomatoes on various root stocks
we've grafted sweet peppers on different
root stocks and we've looked at how they
perform against biotic stresses and
abiotic stresses so we're going to now
present that information that research
to the farmers so that they could see
the possibilities that they could
gain from actually practicing vegetable
grafting vegetable grafting helps in
reducing losses and the amount of money
spent in managing disease problems
it gives the farmer a better chance at
being successful in the enterprise and
in overall production
it also promotes less pesticide use what
ipm tries to do is to discourage the
immediate normally farmers run to
chemicals immediately first stop so we
tried to put chemicals at the as the
last option so vegetable grafting now
would be one of your first options
so
if you have a problem a biotic problem a
bacteria fungus in your soil you can
use this technique to protect your crop
okay so if you're not using the
technique normally the crop would you'd
lost maybe 50 of your crop actual plants
so that means your yield would be
decreased and that directly affects food
security because you you have less
coming from your farm the farmer also
has to spend more in terms of management
so he has more pesticide to buy he has
to pay workers to apply that pesticide
and you have more and then even after
you've done that sometimes you're not
successful in managing that disease so
it costs more and the farmer is
experiencing losses the crop protection
officers indicated that the response
from participating farmers have been
very encouraging and they have
recommended varieties of vegetables that
can be used for grafting
just as impressive
farmers have already been applying the
principles that have been taught
from the ministry of agriculture
fisheries food security and rural
development i'm ryan o'brien